foreign
okay
well it's a very special day because we
have today returning to the pro program
Mike Lindell CEO and inventor of my
pillow what what would you like me to
say David
[Music]
I'm not a lawyer the lawyers are lawyers
what's so hard to understand
[Music]
they can pull these names it's just like
every state every state has people that
voted that don't live in the state hold
it David you're doing the population of
Wisconsin I have a moral compass who
million you can get them I did I got
requests on to everything these are
right are the voter roll David you're
not listening
[Music]
get rid of my espresso machine the
Boating machine David everything that
can be packed you got you know credit
cards companies get hacked businesses
act gas companies act who did this
attack who did this Cyber attack that's
all I'm about we can't have computers
running our election Mike you've
mentioned so much let me just make one
comment here nope nope nope melting down
and turn them into prison bars
[Music]
again
when you have a computer you can change
one number you can do anything you hack
in and you can expect Millions where if
you had to do the same thing with paper
you'd have to have a ball of people you
asked me the dumb question about getting
rid of machines if you want to be a
humorous interview get rid of my
espresso machine
[Music]
[Applause]
what what I'm not a lawyer the lawyers
are lawyers
drama I'm not a lawyer the lawyers are
lawyers yeah
[Music]
you should have one of my pillows too we
are gonna take a moment to recover here
from the extremely high level of energy
I could talk to you all day about this
[Music]
if there is anything that needs to be uh
satirized and remixed it is Trump
talking about massive dumps and by the
way extra points if you can sample Trump
saying massive dumps and me talking
about it in a song please do it
foreign
[Music]
that it was massive dumps that led him
to lose the election which is just on
another level
[Music]
of flushing toilets 10 times 15 times as
opposed to Once
dumps dumps dumps
what is going on here what is go what is
going on here
it's just beyond parody a massive ducks
cost of the election
what is going on here what is the what
is going on here
it's just beyond parody a massive dumps
costume the election
what is on here what is going on
foreign
[Music]
Trump's White House toilet
be clogged
clogged
with documents that Donald Trump was
flushing down the toilet
is this the explanation is this the X
elements
[Music]
mangoes my bags are mangoes
I love mangoes too
nonsense
now that we are up under our body's
regime
my bag of mangoes now cost
[Music]
11.99 that seems like a pretty good deal
a bag of mangoes mango art mangoes
that's it eight or eleven bucks
[Music]
bring my mangoes
the Wisconsin crowd identified with the
mangoes
[Applause]
[Music]
well what an introduction as we continue
to mourn and grieve the death of Elysia
um
I actually forget their name uh diamond
diamond known as Diamond to many of us
we continue to of course grieve the
tragic passing to due to unknown causes
officially but we suspect covid
um thank you for joining me today there
is so much to talk about we're going to
be doing sort of like a clean out the
computer type of stream where we have so
many things to go over the Stephen
Crowder Fiasco the YouTube death spiral
Fiasco Ben Shapiro getting heckled and
then someone in the audience goes to
defend Shapiro and everybody seems
extraordinarily satisfied and pleased
with themselves now I do want to mention
I am already aware many of you writing
to me saying David
the YouTube didn't even tell me you were
live in my algorithm
um or polyrhythm whichever you prefer
and I'm aware folks I I'm I'm aware and
we're going to talk about everything
going on with YouTube and so many
important and different things are going
on so welcome it's great to see
everybody
unfortunately and this is one of the
risks when you promote appearances ahead
of time and I hate that this is going on
I hate I have to do this Lex Friedman
canceled on me
and um
it was not done in the most professional
way
I don't want to go into details or air
dirty laundry but I was scheduled to be
on with Lex Friedman
um Thursday
and it was a last minute cancellation
I I don't want to go into the details it
just doesn't seem professional but
needless to say I do now need to come to
all of you and tell you it didn't happen
it didn't happen that being said next
week I'm going to two different places
I'm going to Florida and I'm going to
Florida in each place I will be doing an
interview I will be on with Patrick Bet
David I will be on with Anthony
pompliano
I will be at the beach I will be off the
beach it's going to be completely crazy
um so hopefully that that'll all still
go down and listen you know what if it
gets canceled it gets canceled and then
I'll come here and I'll eat my hat and
uh it will be what it is okay let's
start with some content I do want to
look at this Super Chat uh chakosec he
says David did you see the tater tots
march on behalf of their lord Andrew
Tate in Greece I actually we could even
start with the um we could start with
the Andrew Tate stuff if people want
uh let me see where do I so here's the
news on Tate first of all Tate is not
wait oh no this article BBC reports
Andrew Tate Romania Court extends police
detention for influencer and brother
yeah so Andrew Tates in jail
um influencer Andrew Tate and his
brother Tristan will stay in custody
until the 27th of February after a
Romanian Court extended police detention
they've been in jail since late December
as they are under investigation for rape
and exploitation they deny the
allegations authorities say they
exploited women by forcing them to
create pornographic content they have
not yet been charged and so have not yet
had the chance to plead guilty or not
guilty
I don't know what this does to the
manosphere
and whether this gives them cred or
makes them look
worse the standards of the manosphere
are so perverted
and backwards that maybe this helps them
or maybe this hurts them I quite
genuinely couldn't tell you
the former kickboxer has millions of
online followers despite being banned
from tick tock's Instagram Facebook and
YouTubes for misogyny his Twitter
account was reactivated in November and
it is active despite his detention
Tate moved to Bucharest five years ago
and was arrested when his house was
raided a lawyer for the Tate Brothers
argued prosecutors had not presented any
new evidence in their application to
extend attention the reasons for the
extension will be given later so that's
going on and meanwhile Tate is not
pleased with the conditions of his
detention
um he claims his prison cell has been
bugged
he is complaining that it is squalid
dark and infested with cockroaches and
lice
the imprisoned ex-kickboxer aired his
complaints in an email to fans
uh he says my first email from
imprisonment they are trying to break me
thrown inside a cell without light
cockroaches lice and bed bugs are my
only friends at night lamented the 36
year old Tate
uh jeez doesn't sound good when the
guards bring me to and from the
courtroom I stay respectful
um
Tate and his brother were arrested
the radialed stacks of money designer
watches and even weapons
um so anyway it doesn't sound like it's
going that well but you know one of the
funny things is like he talked about how
in I I saw a bit of an interview where
Tate seemed to be saying that like with
money in Romania you kind of get
whatever you want you have the police
under your thumb and all these different
things
I wouldn't expect jail conditions to be
good in that type of place if it's the
type of place where I think he said like
that with 10 US Dollars you can I don't
even know what it is you can do with
police if for 10 bucks you can get
favorable police treatment
I wouldn't assume the jails will be nice
I don't know if other people agree on
that but in the types of places where
ten dollars gets you far with police I
assume it will be squalid there will be
at minimum cockroaches for sure for sure
so needless to say trouble in Paradise I
guess for uh for Andrew Tate and uh
and his brother okay so that is all very
much going on thanks to everybody
subscribing via twitch I really do
appreciate that including uh TR napsta
and beast mode and everybody it looks
like one two three
four five six seven eight nine
uh nine people I just I I have so much
going on here thanks to those nine
people I appreciate that over on YouTube
thanks to Joshua cratchman
as well as Elijah parfit and Curtis
Davis for signing up on my website puts
us at 12 people asking about phones yeah
I'll open phones if we get to a hundred
absolutely glad to do that and it looks
like we just did s Prez has just dumped
in a hundred memberships putting us at
112. so I will open phones momentarily
and let's go for two let's get to some
other Clips here here is Ben Shapiro the
Young America Foundation
describes this event this incident as
woke protesters trying to shout down Ben
Shapiro I do want to mention Andrew says
David sir I'm traveling to Miami in
February I believe you've been any
breakfast or dinner recommendations much
appreciated absolutely uh in Miami
um Aegean Mediterranean Bistro is a
beautiful Choice romantic setting if you
like screaming and babies crying I can't
recommend it more highly no um in all
seriousness Aegean Mediterranean
excellent spot a brunch at The Standard
Restaurant I think it's called it's um a
hotel and restaurant in one of those
man-made islands in the intercoastal or
the bay whatever it's called there
highly recommend that silvanos in Miami
Beach is a great spot although I believe
that it's been closed due to a fire
or fire as people from uh Upstate New
York might pronounce it fire is the way
I say it that's a great spot if it's
reopened the sandwichery in Miami Beach
is great
um Shepherd is a nice breakfast spot in
Miami Beach so many spots I'll actually
be in Miami next week
um and it should be should be a good
time
Kratos Orion says do you think anime by
itself negatively influences Society
couldn't tell you I've only ever seen
Spirited Away and nothing else I have
not read any manga or Manga and I have
not seen any other
um anime or anime other than that so I
really couldn't tell you much about it
all right let's get into the Ben Shapiro
clip uh here we go by popular demand so
social justice is an oxymoron okay if a
guilty man is acquitted because he's the
right race that is anti-justice if an
innocent man is convicted because he's
the wrong race that's anti-justice
social justice however suggests that
your group identity your identity as a
person relieves you of individual
responsibility to be a decent human
being imagine wanting to know things and
exist in the world as a knowledgeable
person
and then you're like I'm gonna go to
this lecture series
and I'm going to learn
geez dear God so you get to interrupt
lectures if you're the right race or if
you're the right gender or the right
sexual orientation you get to do these
things without punishment because after
all that's in the nature of social
justice group Justice we don't hold you
responsible for your individual actions
you get extra points in Heaven by the
way you know how they love to say on the
right that people but it's funny people
people in the chat going what the hell
is he talking about I don't know either
like as if I know but I know that he has
grievances he's airing grievances it
wasn't Festivus on this day but he was
participating in the Airing of
Grievances these people love to say that
the left is all about grievances all I
hear from them is self-victimization and
grievances because you were born with a
certain skin color or sexual orientation
[Music]
[Applause]
exactly thank you
okay
wow
compelling stuff folks today all you
hardcore let's just call yourself social
justice Warriors and you do this because
you believe that individual Justice is
racist and sexist and bigoted and
homophobic individual Justice suggest
that we each be held responsible for our
actions but sjws think that's unfair
because we're not just individuals of
course we're members of groups what if
the groups are disproportionately poor
what if they're disproportionately in
jail how can we achieve group Justice if
individual Justice keeps getting in the
way right if it turns out that certain
groups have more members in jail
disproportionately it's funny because
Ben has a reputation for being just
having this incredible Clarity when he
speaks
where you know it's impossible to
misunderstand or not understand what
he's saying this is nonsense this is a
word salad B because something deeply
wrong has happened something the system
is rigged against that group it can't be
because a lot of individuals within that
particular group have committed crimes
now the problem with this logic is it
sounds sort of bad if you think of
people only in terms of their racial or
ethnic groups or their sexual
orientation that's sort of racist it's
sort of homophobic it's actually sort of
discriminatory you're not any better a
person for being black or gay or Jewish
this doesn't mean anything social group
is only important if the social group is
propagating good things yeah just
arbitrarily group people about skin
color that's that's just called
tribalism racial diversity doesn't
actually mean anything
[Applause]
I want to get to the part where the
based lady fires back but I don't know
where that is
man it is troubling that so many young
people are wasting their time at an
event like this
foreign
[Music]
whoa bass lady wow she's firing back
Standing Ovation for based lady oh and
look Shapiro's clapping
look at this
this is the epitome of virtue signaling
tribalism it's it's very it's a it's no
longer really ironic because the values
of these people are actually the
opposite of what they claim and it's
been that way for a long time but it's
everything about this is vert it's the
very virtue signaling that these people
criticize the left for
foreign
hard-working person sounds like as
opposed to a loser student here on the
public dime presumably
Public University everybody here is
presumably on the public time okay yeah
just criticize the criticize the entire
crowd perfect that beautifully done
um this stuff is great I mean you you
you learn nothing from this other than I
guess that these people are hypocrites
you know a big thank you to office
drummer who just resubscribed on Twitch
office drummer top-notch streamer you
can find office drummer drumming on tick
tocks YouTubes and twitch all over the
place very very exciting to see you as
well as the shoplifting empath and Joe
sauce which puts us at 115 members we
will open phone lines folks we are
opening phone lines because uh we did
get to a hundred new members all right
let's go to some Candace Owens drivel
and insanity
she is now targeting Greta tunberg
um and says that Greta tunberg is in
need of an exorcism
I guess she assumes or believes exorcism
is real I don't know let's uh oh and we
have a super chat
owners of means of production socialism
Is Better Than People communism is
better than State capitalism is better
than corporations I've been learning
that I get it right extrol man man I
don't know what Juan is talking about uh
let's continue with Candace Owens in
case you haven't seen this it is going
viral because it's incredible it
shouldn't shock you Greta thundberg
obviously I've discussed her many times
on this show uh she's something about
her is incredibly dark I can't I can't
quite pick up on it but she from the
time she's hit the scene she just seems
to me to be in need of an exorcism you
look at her and you're like this isn't
this this is actually a genius concept
obviously exorcism is nonsense right
the idea that you would identify someone
as whose characteristic is that they are
in need of such an uh an exorcism which
is nonsense is endlessly fascinating
unhappy individual Trump once called her
an unhappy child while she's no longer a
child anymore I think she's almost 20 or
20 years old and she still looks like a
child and she still got some weird
spiritual
weirdness about her I can explain it
there's just something about it isn't
Greta tunberg just autistic like that's
all that it is
it's dark there's a very dark energy and
uh you need an exorcism and
it's all very very strange I thought
Greta tunberg was was just autistic and
you know had some social kind of
you know uh struggles or something like
that I don't know about her that I'm
around her I just I just think this is
the orphan if you've seen that movie she
reminds me of the orphan and I don't
want to be near her I just when I see
her I think I would not go near does
Owens regularly have an opportunity to
go near her that person because there
was a Darkness over her well I've set my
personal feelings aside uh what is going
on right these aren't her person
where she's going to put aside her
personal feelings guys viral is the fact
that she has been caught staging her
arrest that's been debunked I mean there
is no other way to describe this other
than these are a hired actors
she is a hired actress she's been a
higher actress for a very long time and
she is staging herself pretending that
she is being arrested in Germany because
it's shocking to me anyone even pays
attention to Greta tunberg to this
degree like you know grettoonberg has
had some viral moments and whatever like
I don't find her super interesting
I don't really care one way or the other
but it's just like why are you so
obsessed with Greta tunberg
but I mean just if if you're if you find
her whatever just don't pay attention as
she was protesting the expansion of a
coal mine now why would they explain
that coal mine because obviously Germany
and Europe is facing an energy crisis at
this moment
and they've been facing energy crisis
for a while and so they were expanding a
coal mines that Elders wouldn't freeze
throughout the winter so citizens
wouldn't freeze but forget it Owens is
doing that thing where every statement
is like said like a question you know
the climb activists don't care about
human beings it's quite the opposite
they hate Humanity right they want
everything to survive but human beings
and so she staged herself protesting it
didn't actually protest it and here is
how do people watch this crap seriously
you know one of the things we're doing
today is I have this backlog
everything's very packed in
of different clips and and things people
have sent and my colleague John sent you
know to so that we could take a look at
it
I don't know how people get through this
stuff I don't even have time to watch
the things I like I don't have the time
to read the books I like
and people watch this stuff
it's it's crazy
Newsmax guest urges viewers to call
9-1-1 if they see a trans person
Patriot Barbie host Lindsey Graham
oh my god let's look at that in a moment
let me just read this a super chat from
jabroni jabroni says wanted to support
and to let you know unlike all other
channels I watch yours doesn't have the
red highlight that it is live and won't
bring you here yet something is very
very screwy with what's happening on
YouTube I'm going to get to that a
little bit later
uh we're gonna get to that momentarily
thanks to Chris Weiss Miller Brad Smith
and Eric Snyder for signing up on my
website putting us at 118 for the day
all right let's continue okay here's an
idea about trans from Newsmax and
Lindsay I want to show something uh that
you posted it's a video let's take a
listen
he agrees himself that he's a man
I have told the police that I was in the
locker room a man was in there I was
getting undressed he looked at me he is
a man in the women's locker room
and the response is that this is a
touchy sensitive issue in society
wow so you you see a man in the women's
locker room at your gym police refused
to act because it was as you said a
touchy subject uh what can we do about
this because that just seems ridiculous
you're not saying it was a man who was
dressed as a woman who may have been
trans it was just it was not a man who
was dressed as a woman a dude in the
locker room
it's it's a dude I mean legitimately
it's a dude he dresses like a woman he
calls himself a woman eats against the
children and at his Elementary School
call him either call or Miss Bixler you
guys are smart children are smart this
is a man there's no doubt about it
unfortunately what he did is he went to
his local DMV he had his driver's
license changed she's like I checked his
prostate it was definitely a dude you
should say female and that is what tied
the hands of the police oh my God
Arizona
I encourage all women all women across
the United States Across America across
the world if you see a biological man if
you see a man in a private uh secure
space that belongs to by the way
um just recently at the gym
I saw a woman very very similar to this
woman
uh wearing a Ron DeSantis 2024 tank top
so those exist interestingly
for women you call 9-1-1 you call the
police you do not go to the front desk
you do not ask a minimum wage employee
to help you take care of what is a very
very scary situation you call the police
yeah and even if it was super scary
man this so I've said before this is the
obsession right now for a while you know
the
they were never really obsessed with
lesbians like when I interviewed this
homophobe Brian Fisher a long time ago
he he would talk about lesbians and he
would be like oh lesbians have higher or
you know this or that I don't know but
lesbians were like the most acceptable
all along but they were focused on gay
men for a very long time you know gay
men are pedophiles was it the thing that
would go on and
um based on Evolution gay men shouldn't
exist for a while it was gay men that
they were obsessed with
they've I don't I I don't want to
falsely say that the anti-lgbt right is
now fine with gay men but they've kind
of moved on from gay men where now the
obsession is really
um trans people and mostly trans women
right uh trans men
they seem to care about a lot less I
don't know if people in the chat agree
on that but it seems really trans women
is the obsession with you know the
weightlifting stories and all of that
sort of thing so I'm sure it'll all
Circle back as as there as they
experience victories and losses in this
fight
um I'm sure it'll all Circle back
um but uh that this is the obsession
right now and oh and drag queens very
good point yeah Beth in the chat saying
they're also obsessed with drag queens
right now like George Anthony kitara
devolder Santos
that's not a joke okay there is a person
whose real name at this point I couldn't
tell you what it is
um who
performed is that the right word I mean
we'll talk about it tomorrow on the show
performed under the name Katara as a
drag queen
is now an elected member of Congress and
some of you might know him as George
Santos some of you might know him as
Anthony devolder
some of you might know him as you know a
Pioneer in the field of cardiothoracic
surgery
um I don't know him that way but maybe
some of you know him that way he's an
importer exporter architect marine
biologist of sorts
um anyway we'll talk we'll talk more
about that tomorrow in all in all in
complete seriousness thanks to Jason
sickmeyer and Ann cloward for signing up
at joinpakman.com numbers uh one members
119 and 120 I will be opening phone
lines momentarily but I do have a bunch
of other stuff to look at here is Ron
DeSantis the Florida governor explaining
why they have canceled an
African-American history course I think
you will find this very interesting what
are one what's one of the lessons about
queer Theory now who would say that an
important part of black history is queer
theory that is somebody pushing an
agenda on our kids and so when you look
to see they have the class is an
elective
an elective class that is being pushed
on the 12 kids that will choose to take
it but it's still being pushed you've
got to cancel it stuff about
intersectionality abolishing prisons
that's a political agenda and so we're
on that's the wrong side of the line for
Florida standards what are one so that's
been canceled and we tomorrow on the
show I will talk to you about how
education is going in Florida it's not
going particularly well Congressman Jim
Banks is supporting efforts to prevent
women from leaving Indiana to find an
abortion listen to this our work as a
pro-life movement is far from over if if
a young lady can hop in a car in Fort
Wayne yeah and in an hour and a half she
can be in a place in Michigan or in just
under three hours she could cross the
line into Illinois right and Achieve
what she was able to do with abortion
clinics here in Indiana the fight is far
from over right that's exactly right and
I I'm for a federal legislation I'm for
stronger laws at the state levels
whatever we whatever ban people from
switching States we believe in
free travel between states and we
believe in federal Supremacy in the
Constitution and oh block people from
changing states to Avail themselves
of Medical Services wow small government
conservatism what we can do to save
lives to protect babies that's that's
what this fight is all about yep these
people are sick
these people are absolutely and
completely sick
um I don't know how many of you have
been following what's going on with
Stephen Crowder apparently Stephen was
offered some kind of four-year 50
million dollar contract by the daily
wire it would give them if I recall
correctly
four weeks off a year
and Fridays off but I guess he was upset
that it didn't include like paid sick
time or something like that
um let's see what he's up to
big Tech is in bed with big con
the people you thought
the people I thought were fighting for
you
a lot of it has been
a big con now I'm specifically avoiding
naming names or going after individuals
in this video right because I genuinely
hope that those I'm addressing and you
know who you are have a change of heart
don't sign don't sign these contracts
I know I now know what you are signing
out there I have the luxury of not
having to you know let me go through
this if any of the major platforms
issues a Content strike such that
Crowder cannot be monetized on such
platform the fee will be reduced by 25
it would only be
you will only have a 37 and a half
million dollar contract if you get a
copyright strike and we can't monetize
any of your content
do you guys see how the capitalists have
this poor worker
over a barrel
they will take away 12 and a half
million over four years if he gets a
copyright strike twenty percent of it
happens on Apple and then another 10 of
happens on Facebook and then another ten
percent of it happens on Spotify what a
wage slave
he needs a little marks and then if you
get a strike
meaning a suspension another 20 just to
drive it home you get hit by a car you
have a sick day you can lose a hundred
thousand dollars a day this is what
I could listen guys do you realize that
if I'm out for a week with covid
uh that's five working days that's half
a million dollars it immediately reduces
my contract's value from 50 million to
49.5 million dollars
wow
absolutely sickening huh totally
incredible stuff
um okay so now people have been weighing
in about the Crowder stuff so like
here's Candace Owens
she is going after Crowder and it seems
that they're now starting to gang up on
crowder at the end of the day I think
what happened this is my completely my
opinion by the way so I'm not blinking
twice about under duress is that Stephen
Crowder became a free agent and he's
feeling a little vulnerable right now
right he's used to working for other
organizations he has some guaranteed pay
and he thought that daily wire were
actually going to meet him at 120
million dollars they didn't they
declined and he's still feeling a little
shaky on that it's scary he's really
shaken up guys you know it's oh hold on
is she saying it's scary to only get 50.
a million dollars they didn't they
declined and he's still feeling a little
shaky on that it's it's scary to go out
on your own I thought
talking about it I thought I was going
going on my own it's a lot of work maybe
down the line I will but it's a scary
thing yeah you know what's scary this
right here okay guys this is what we're
going to talk about later this is scary
having to accept 50 million instead of
120 that's not scary
okay that's not scary this is scary okay
when you see this
and we'll talk about that
man these people what what planet do
these people live on to go out to step
out on your own and say I'm going to do
this thing completely by myself as
Jeremy pointed out Steve has not done
that before right and so to do this he
pulled a move in which he was going to
try to take a bunch of people that were
subscribed to the Daily wire and start
his own company so essentially say I'm
the hero I'm the Martyr follow me
because I'm not like those guys then he
was going to start his own shop and
that's what he's trying to do and some
people fell for it and said I'm with you
and I'm a mug Club till I die and didn't
understand that really nothing happened
here other than nobody wanted to pay
Stephen Crowder 120 million dollars yeah
so he turned to his viewers so he thinks
are stupid stupid definitely understand
how business negotiations work right
like this is like normal you kick it
back and forth and they we're gonna make
up for his loss so people that are upset
by his video the million of millions
people who watched it are you guys
following this all right that's that's
enough I can't even deal with it here's
another Candace Owens clip says she has
certain information about Stephen
Crowder now this I'm more interested in
over the weekend I was given a lot more
information regarding Stephen Crowder a
lot more background information
regarding what could have possibly led
to this moment yeah and
not to my surprise at all obviously this
really doesn't have anything to do with
the daily wire and his actions are a
symptom of much something much larger
and I want to choose they're a symptom
of munch that's that's shocking very
carefully here because I'm Not Angry
Anymore
Stephen has a lot going on I guess is
the best way to say it he has a lot
going on and that should be clear
because people don't do stuff like this
if there's not a lot going on in their
lives you don't sell out your friend you
don't record conversations these things
are actions profound life advice from
Candace Owens jewels that are perhaps
acting out of desperation you have to
dig deep where you have to look deeper
to fully understand the picture of why
somebody might do that and it's
certainly not because somebody is upset
with a 50 million dollar contract and
because I now am more aware of certain
information rather than being angry I
would like to implore my audience and
everybody that isn't paying attention to
this situation not to condemn him but to
pray for him right sometimes he needs
prayer and an exorcist we'll need a
prayer sometimes people need a scripture
you know Stephen purports to be a
Christian and I believe that he needs to
lean in to his faith and I am certain
that in the near future more information
will come out I do not think it is my
place to say more than that well
probably what I should say is I am
unsure at this moment if it is my place
to say more than that it's not you know
maybe if I feel in further defense some
things should be said or maybe if I feel
that the public has a right how ominous
guys how ominous understand certain
circumstances but at this moment I think
I would just like to carefully back out
there you go so uh Candace Owens is
opting out she's backing out of the
entire thing of what I don't we don't
know Crowder really wanted 120 million
and it's scary
it's scary he might have to go for only
he might have to work four years for
only a million dollars a month
and when you're going out on your own
that's scary
that's very very scary guys we're gonna
open phones on Discord momentarily Bay
photo says Hassan is absolutely right
daily wire Revenue doesn't add up to be
able to offer these large contracts to
people like Crowder not without Capital
injections from right-wing billionaires
oh a hundred percent a hundred percent
that's I didn't even think that was a
question of course daily wire isn't
going to generate 50 million in in
revenue from there that's being
subsidized by billionaire right Wingers
it's not even it's not even a question
not even a question all right uh before
we open the phone lines
um
ah you guys want to know what's going on
listen listen to this thing that's going
on I'm going to tell you this story as I
told it in a YouTube clip and then I
already have more information okay
January 9th
we noticed hey um
we're not getting any views like it's
four o'clock we're publishing our Clips
we're doing all the stuff we normally do
we are getting no views like it's just
it's blank it's blanked out
what the hell is going on here
this didn't only happen to us okay
what happened to some other channels I
was I was hearing from other people
um and we all contacted YouTube and
YouTube said this is a glitch you're
getting all the views you normally get
trust me you're getting all the views
you normally get
it's a reporting glitch and we're going
to figure it out okay that you didn't
really get no views during that time
all right fine
the next day
we get some views but I can tell and
many of my colleagues you know them I'm
not gonna I'm not gonna call them out
it's up to them to tell you who they are
we notice we're getting views but it's
like almost none this is very weird
and as many of you know we have 1.6
million subscribers we have you know
videos that do well which get a million
views and we have videos that do okay
which get 250 000 views and there's some
like bottom limit when you have 1.6
million subscribers and like none of our
Clips would typically get below uh 15
000 views 10 000 views okay whatever but
days and days and then weeks go by and
we're just not getting any views we at a
day January 15th where we lost three
subscribers net
it's been years and years and years and
years we gained subscribers right we
gain hundreds if not thousands of
subscribers typically and there's this
period where we're basically flat
what the hell is going on
and then we see videos that are getting
under 2 000 views in the first 90 to 120
Minutes look at this
first hour and 35 minutes 1.4
000 views what
two hours and 20 minutes oh sorry this
one you can't see there it is 2 000
views something is very very very
clearly wrong now if I were
conspiratorial I would say the man or
some person has flipped a switch and is
deliberately trying to hurt my channel
because I'm on the left or something
I'm not saying that I don't have
evidence of that okay but what I do know
is that after this glitch on January 9th
the channel has been dead
down 70 percent in views down 70 percent
in Revenue down 70 percent in
subscribers
what happened
we don't know okay
what's my next thing uh we're not there
okay so I started hearing from many of
you
who said to me hold on let me see if I
can get the right
image here
it is who said to me stuff like this
okay
this is all based on anecdotes but I
believe it applies to your YouTube
issues says Tom I exclusively scroll
through recently uploaded but other
categories are similarly populated by an
algorithm I noticed a month or two ago I
stopped seeing your videos recommended I
had to manually search for your channel
to find
this also happened to other favorite
creators all of those and your channel
have one thing in common I started to
ignore their video your videos on
YouTube because I watched them elsewhere
since then I noticed that whenever I
click on the recently uploaded section
has a massive impact on what is
recommended in the future
I believe that what happened is the
following this glitch on January 9th
was a recalibration of the algorithm and
I'm going to support that in a moment
okay that recalibration
created some intermediate period during
which my videos were briefly not
recommended
the fact that then our click-through
rate
diminished
signaled to YouTube no one wants to see
this guy's videos don't recommend them
anymore
okay now I now have reason to believe
this goes beyond just YouTube
I have started to get emails from people
who work in SEO okay now we're talking
about Google search and they told me
David it's not just YouTube January 9th
half my clients stopped getting traffic
to their website from you from Google
Search
this is a bigger
realignment and it is screwing some
people
I am not alleging anyone said let's
screw David Pacman I am not alleging
anybody said let's screw left-wing
YouTube
but I believe that some people have been
absolutely crushed by this okay now I
have heard even during the stream David
you went live I didn't see your live
stream YouTube is supposed to prioritize
life I went to my subscriptions nothing
you're not in there okay
however
I have some really great people
to thank
where the hell is my stuff I don't even
know where is anything where all of my
images are gone
hold on where the hell is this
Dear God
here it is okay
go over here
this is what I believe we need to do
I think in order to test whether this is
nefarious or whether this is simply the
result of let's call it an accident
we need to retrain the the YouTube
algorithm okay so I am asking you with
peace and love with my two most recent
videos okay that's the clip about what's
going on
and this clip about Trump's eulogy of
diamond with these two clips okay go to
these clips like these clips comment on
these clips make damn sure that you were
subscribed okay let's retrain the
algorithm I believe if a few thousand
people do this we may fix the problem
okay so make a hundred percent sure you
were subscribed
super easy
make sure you have hit the bell and you
said you want to be notified about my
videos
make sure that you have hit the like
button
uh uh okay let's see if we can fix this
now I do have some exciting news
this is today okay this is thanks to you
already starting to do this we met and
see I wasn't lying when I said it's
typical that we get a hundred thousand
views an hour at this time of day it has
been dead for the last 48 hours but
thanks to some of you
we are starting to see the numbers
slightly recover will this fix the
problem I don't have a clue in hell I
genuinely don't have a clue in Hell okay
but this is all we've got because it's
quite literally killing our YouTube
channel now if you're watching on Twitch
rep just do what you can okay
thankfully we are whoa
a thousand subscriptions just dumped in
it's looking like we are maybe starting
to fix this it is insane we have to do
this it is insane that we have to do
this now in all seriousness we're about
to launch the Spanish Channel
it's thousands of dollars a month to get
our content dubbed into Spanish we were
we were using the YouTube Revenue to do
that the YouTube revenue is now down 70
so if you're willing to sign up at
joinpakman.com I would really really
really really appreciate it and I want
to thank people who have already done
that I want to say thanks to Justin Howe
as well as Larry Trott
Edgar Bowen and Luke Broderick all of
whom just got subscriptions on my
website dump in a twitch subscription
like Captain Planet just did whatever
okay this is where we are I don't have
any other ideas I'm not a legend
conspiracy I'm not alleging anybody who
is saying let's target Pac-Man I'm just
saying it it's what it is okay so what
I'm asking is find our two most recent
videos YouTube nuked my YouTube channel
that's one
Trump visibly confused and complaining
that Diamond's funeral is too long
number two if we can do that I think we
might be able to retrain fails over
president Donald dear God uh we might be
able to retrain the algorithm 4 500
comments already here and 23 000 likes
those are big numbers folks okay the
Trump video okay not doing quite as well
but still 5 000 likes let's see what we
can do let's see what we can do I can
think of nothing else to fix this
problem let's open the phones okay we
are going to open the phones I promise
we would do it we do this via Discord at
davidpackman.com Discord this is the oh
yeah people are saying this is the
problem with with big Tech there's no
transparency that's exactly right
I don't know what's going on I'm just
trying to deal with an algorithm that
has gotten completely Haywire let's hear
from people because I promised that I
would if we get to 100 new members today
and we did okay you go to
davidpackman.com Discord you join the
waiting Lobby uh let's see start the
stage
live stream calls we're going to call it
start stage
and okay let's hear from some of you I
promised I would do this so let's
absolutely do it right now before I jump
into that we've got a Super Chat sir it
appears the algorithm missed you and is
happy to see you live again thank you
Bay photo appreciate that
um very very important stuff okay let's
just jump right in and talk to some
people here all right let's start with
um oh I don't know how about Jerry from
Detroit Jerry from Detroit let's hope we
have no Tech issues today it's great to
be here it's great to be live what is
going on with you sir
David sir thank you for choosing me I
appreciate it can you hear me pleasure I
can hear you beautifully
excellent excellent Okay cool so I just
have a very simple question for you yes
lately I've been seeing a lot of leftist
news commentators in the space get into
video gaming here and there a good
example that I can think of Hassan ABI
becoming majorly addicted to valeran
what is it to Valentines
valorent oh oh my God I don't even know
what that is yeah it's one of those
video games that you shoot people in but
you know there's plenty of other kinds
of video games out there yeah of course
do you plan on getting into a video game
at some point you know I really don't
particularly with a baby now uh it's
hard enough even to stream so the idea
that now I'm gonna get big into video
games it's not feeling super likely
that's totally fair I appreciate your
time though David is if I did is there a
particular game I should get into
oh man you know what there's all kinds
of them out there but I've lately been
into this one called rimworld very uh
very fun all right well we will look
into it sir thank you thank you all
right there is Jerry from Detroit
weighing in let's go next to George from
Virginia George welcome to the stream
it's a pleasure to host you today
hey David can you hear me yes I can
perfect perfect
um so I wanted to uh quickly discuss
your issues with the algorithm please
um so I don't know if you remember but
uh you remember you were doing like a
survey to see who would uh want to learn
how to build a YouTube channel
yes I do remember that yeah so I
actually signed up for it
um but I didn't hear anything back but
anyways I had a YouTube channel uh
not the one I'm logged in now but it was
a channel I made for gaming like uh like
a year ago yeah and I was I was growing
pretty fast
and then I started making uh videos
criticizing Google for their uh stadia
prod product yeah that that they did
shut down uh last year because I
actually predicted it in one of my
videos anyways after I started doing
that I started getting no views and I
was actually growing pretty fast and
then it all went to a halt How many
views were your videos getting
uh so I was very small but I was getting
up to 20 000 views on my best videos
which is actually pretty good for like a
no name no that is and how many
subscribers did you get up to
I got up to almost I I think 398 but it
was like in the first year which is like
super slow growth yeah but once I
started criticizing Google yep it just
immediately went off a cliff well
Georgia it is anecdotal uh but it is
interesting to hear and I appreciate you
sharing that with us
okay thank you all right pleasure there
is George let's go next to Cody from
Hamilton Cody from Hamilton welcome to
the live stream what is on your mind
hey David can you hear me yes I can
hey uh I was just curious um I heard
some uh recent European news uh turkey
sounds like I might be blocking Sweden's
Ascension to Nato uh not Finland just
Sweden from what I've heard and I was
curious if you have any thoughts on um
either of the two or even I guess
Ukraine and uh our relationship with
these countries in NATO well I mean I
have I have General thoughts I I have to
admit I have not followed that
particular element closely so I wouldn't
be able to weigh in on the turkey uh
Sweden situation but you know generally
my view is I I want
I believe that it is fair to say
that it could be that the expansion of
NATO could theoretically be interpreted
as aggression right this was a story
that was big in the start of the Ukraine
Russia Fiasco
um but at the same time
it is of course
within a country's right to want to join
and
to be evaluated and considered and the
repercussions to countries for joining
seem completely unacceptable now
diplomatically a country could say you
know we are starting to feel as though
we are being ganged up on because of the
members that are joining it I'm totally
fine with that that's a geopolitical
discussion but for the purposes of of
justifying military action uh I am not
at all convinced that NATO membership
would even remotely be a justifiable
explanation for military action
oh that's interesting oh just curious
though thanks for taking my question all
right Cody from Hamilton appreciate
hearing from you let's go to Rusty in
Tucson Arizona now you might not think
Tucson is a place that I've spent much
time in or that I like but I've spent
much time in Tucson and I like it very
much uh Rusty you've been invited to
speak I'm I'm waiting for you to accept
once you do you will be on welcome Rusty
thank you I had to put my job aside for
a moment yeah too I've spent a lot of
time in Tucson I I'm you know I have
friends there I have had a great time I
don't love sort of like how spread out
it is like no matter where you go it's
10 to 12 miles away you know which in
the Northeast is like you're in a
different County if you go 10 to 12
miles but
um an okay food scene and great hiking
and I I have enjoyed my time in Tucson
very much
and recreational weed makes it a little
more tolerable if you ever back if you
ever back the tacos around me I like
that I had great tacos while there
all right so this is a conversation
that's kind of come up in your Discord
quite often I want to get your opinion
on it please now
what can even be reasonably done about
the gun violence situation in America at
this point
well when you say what can be done do
you mean what ideas are there for for
changes that could be made or
politically what is actually actually
possible honestly I I'd say it's a bit
of both I mean after the uh recent
gigantic shooting I thought the gun
control bill that Congress passed was
completely toothless right
I was shocked that the semi-auto age
wasn't raised to 21 and I say that as
someone that owns many semi-autos yeah
but listen here's the thing in terms of
what can be done I've outlined 10 to 12
different things limiting magazine
capacity uh requiring
um eliminating every loophole on
background checks requiring additional
screening for anyone under 25 including
Community letters of support from adults
who can meaningfully speak to this is a
person I'm completely comfortable with
having firearms a mandatory waiting
period restricting certain Firearms to
people under 25 from people under 25 you
know it's a very long list and of course
the gun nuts will always say
not know one of those things would
prevent every shooting to which of
course I would say well but they would
prevent some and that's that's progress
so so there's a very very long list in
terms of what's politically feasible I
couldn't tell you maybe nothing you know
I mean it's just um I I just don't even
know at this point what this
Congress could even do even Nexus near
session away from now because the
country's become so polarized and you
know hateful I agree
well I'll go and let you go I appreciate
your time I think the ATF just turned me
into a felon so I got to go buy a longer
AR-15 Barrel keep it high in tight I'll
talk to you later all right there you go
Rusty is high and tight in Tucson very
very exciting to hear from about that
let's go next to Ariel also in Arizona
Ariel welcome to the program what is on
your mind today
hey can you hear me yes I can
uh
can you hear me yes I still can
oh
hold on I'm trying to figure out how I
can turn
everything seems fine okay and Ariel is
gone Ariel is gone all right wow a lot a
lot is happening here let's go to cardi
from Los Angeles cardi welcome to the
program what's going on
cardi welcome to the program
what are you up to
and the last opportunity for cardi to
join bringing the stream to a grinding
halt
all right well no cardi let's go to
Gustavo from Newton Gustavo welcome to
the program
Gustavo you've been invited but you have
to accept please
hello yes
hey hi how you doing man I'm doing well
great great
um I had a quick question uh
Spanish dub the show
you know it's very interesting you're
cutting in and out uh and it's it's very
unusual
okay hold on now that was fine though
that was fine
I'm fine now yeah that's fine okay X oh
God now you're cutting it my dad would
really
really absolutely my dad speaks dominant
so
you know a show like that would really
help um I just had a quick question are
you planning on making it uh the dub the
voice over dub person the dubbing
um an Argentine span you know we were
not able that we're working with a
dubbing company that is based in
Argentina but they okay perfect but hold
on I don't know you're gonna like the
answer because they tend to work with
people who speak more neutral Spanish
for it to be more accessible to all of
Latin America so the dubbing will set I
thought it would be interesting since
I'm Argentinian for the dubbing into the
Spanish channel to be done with an
Argentina accent but it's not going to
be it's not going to be oh man all right
well I just was wondering because um
somebody in the chat was saying well
David don't speak Spanish so why don't
you do it I'm too busy I just have too
much going on to do the yeah
exactly exactly no so that was that was
my question thank you so much my
pleasure I'm Gonna Let You Go Gustavo
just because the connection is very very
illegal Danny says via Super Chat long
time supporter here excited for the
Spanish dub of your channel and the
impact it'll have
in the U.S and abroad absolutely
absolutely I want to say thanks to Jason
sickmeyer Blake Daniel Ryan Phipps Ben
coletan and Brendan Fletcher for signing
up on my website putting us at 130 new
members for the day also thanks to
Watergirl and hoppy for the twitch Prime
subscriptions we are speaking to people
via Discord why because I said I would
and I stick to my word let's go next to
oh I don't know how about Jesse from
Melbourne Jesse from Melbourne Australia
welcome what is it like 8 A.M there on
Tuesday
uh it's about 11 A.M now 11 A.M wait so
you're you're
16 hours ahead is that even possible
apparently sorry wow that it seems like
it shouldn't be possible but okay I
believe you Jesse the feature is cool
yeah um my question so I would in
Australia lost last may we had an
election and before the election the
center right right-wing government was
very corrupt and so we voted them out
pretty heavily okay but they we had
calls for a national anti-croportion
commission yes we have in each state and
at the election the central left labor
campaigns on it and they got into
government and it's been legislated
they're going to implement it in a few
months now what I wanted to ask was what
are the chances of that happening in the
U.S and what impact
extremely low I hate to tell you it's
extremely low I mean listen the house
House Republicans just took control of
the house and they weakened ethics rules
for themselves you know there is not an
appetite for this in the in much of the
United States
yeah it's sad's here but it's extremely
sad what did happen in Australia though
was each state and territory set up
their own version of this beforehand do
you think it's likely that any states
particularly the blue States will look
at doing that in the future as well
maybe I I mean
oh you know it the thing is it'll just
end up being like everything else
something the blue states that don't
need to do it will be the only ones that
do it
yeah
it's it's a bit of a bummer I have to
say
yeah well let's just hope it works out
here first that way hopefully it will
influence out the countries to start
adopting the same thing and hopefully a
little corruption all together you know
I I have never been to Australia or New
Zealand but I would I would really love
to visit I think it would be an
extraordinary experience
yeah it's a beautiful country lovely
people here as well what's the deal with
the cuisine there
um
we have like a lot of different Cuisines
so we eat a lot of pouring food there's
not like too big of an Australian
Cuisine only we do like kangaroos
um
but yeah there's there's pretty good
restaurants around where I live in
Melbourne we're known we're well known
for our worldwide restaurants so if you
come down here it's a great place to be
for um just the vibe in the city
can can you get a good bagel in
Melbourne
I I think so I haven't really thought
about that I don't I'm not too into
Bagels but I assume you can all right
well I would be interested in finding
out let's put it that way
yeah all right Jesse thank you very much
for the call
thank you all right there goes Jesse
from Melbourne Australia not super
confident on the bagel stuff
uh oh look we actually might roll over
to a full 1.6 million subscribers during
this stream that is interesting I like
that
um okay Austin says David sir my Super
Chat supports you and Google what do I
do not think about it too much Austin is
what I would do I wouldn't devote too
too much time to it let's go to grill
from Worcester Massachusetts
Grill from the 508 welcome to the
program what is on your mind today
you've got to unmute yourself Grill and
then I'll be able to hear you
oh hi can you hear me now yes Grill well
what kind of a name is Grill
what is that what what sort of name is
Grill is that a nickname or is that
short for something
oh it's an alias okay fair I'll be
honest
well what is on your mind today Grill
okay my what's on my mind is
um are you you're from Massachusetts
right well I'm from Argentina I I went
to school in Massachusetts
um yes so I grew up in Massachusetts
yeah okay well I'm from Massachusetts
too and I've spent a lot of time well
for for some reason I'm under the
impression that you're from Western Mass
is that right I grew up in western Mass
that's right
so I've was it Northampton yep okay so I
want to know what your favorite
restaurant there was
you know the thing about Northampton
restaurants is a lot of them never
lasted that long so you know it's like
places went in and out the the
restaurant scene was always
extraordinarily
unpredictable let's say so you know I I
don't know I mean growing up there was
this Mexican place Cha Cha Cha which I
really liked and then there was a place
called Molino's Italian which eventually
I think became carmeliness I'm not even
sure the evolution like I loved going to
Molinos when I was a kid
um you know for seafood I would go to
Paul and Elizabeth's uh I it's so it's
just so hard to say
that is true I mean they do change a lot
but I know that one of going really
basic there's been a pizza place there
for a while I think it's memos
I just saw some friends from from from
home post that memos is gone although
honestly I don't even know that it's
been called memos for a while I
genuinely am unsure
okay yeah they had giant slices of pizza
there but I guess it was not that
special yeah I think that that place
went through some name changes even it's
kind of depressing
yep sounds it yeah well that's all I
wanted to do is connect with you on
being
um knowing living in Massachusetts well
you know you are from Sam Cedar's home
who is that oh boy all right Grill I'm
Gonna Let You Go okay thank you for the
call
you're welcome okay boy I gotta get away
from that please do not send that to Sam
okay do not send that to Sam or maybe do
and maybe he'll respond to that uh
tomorrow on his on his program geez that
was a sad sad sad moment let's go to
Jack from Ocean Shore uh Jack from Ocean
Shore please welcome to the program
what's going on
oh thank you for taking my call David
pleasure
sorry you called on me right as I was
eating uh
a chip just a single chip that's
suspicious
I just I just finished my cup of hummus
you drank hummus
no no no uh pre-packaged cups of hummus
oh my God okay
so anyway yeah I was um wanting to see
if you had heard
uh Washington State here were hopefully
going to have some sort of vote on
universal like a universal health
coverage for the state for everybody in
the state yeah
um but as of right now I'm I was just
looking and and I haven't seen any any
new updates but I know that we were
actively trying to
get signatures for this legislative
session so I guess it might be still a
little early so it's not even on the
ballot right now they're Gathering
signatures to make it a ballot
initiative is that right
I believe so for
this I I've if my memory is correct
it's for this year but
I just got over coveted so memory is not
exactly
the best anyway yeah uh
well listen it sounds interesting I know
nothing about it but I will I will look
into it
great and uh I was thinking about you
when I had brunch the other day uh oh
yeah just that you know this is a good
brunch place and if I ever told if I
could never have I become so uh
associated with brunch that when people
have brunch they think of me I don't
know that that's the imagery that I'm
going for necessarily
well as an audience member and I spend a
lot of time online yep it's almost like
uh
pseudo relationship it's not a real
relationship but you know
I think of people like that
anyway anyway it's something that I do
Jack thank you for the call I appreciate
it oh you're welcome there is Jack from
Ocean Shores very very powerful stuff
let's go to Joseph from Virginia Joseph
welcome to the program what's on your
mind today
Joseph from Virginia welcome to the
program
all right let's try River from India
River from India welcome to the program
River you're on you just have to select
the correct audio device and everyone
will be able to hear you
okay am I on now you're on right now
yeah
often
um how are you doing David I'm doing
well
okay I'm curious in your thoughts on job
TPT and Google change and ethical stance
uh to releasing their
um their GPT is faster uh or attempting
to release the gpd's faster in order to
um get ahead of the market competition
River I'm sorry I don't know what you're
talking about the Captivity of chat GPT
no no no no no I'm sorry my mic maybe my
mic maybe uh okay I said I'm curious in
your thoughts on chart GPT and Google's
change in ethical stance oh uh to
release their own
um their own machine learning products
faster yeah in order to get ahead of the
market competition you know I don't know
what Google is doing yet I have a
handful of Articles bookmarked about
this exact issue and I didn't get to I
would be reading them right now were it
not for this stream
um I wanna I wanna look into that I
don't know what Google is doing but I'm
very interested in the fact that Google
has started to act very quickly and you
know what is interesting
I I have started to use chat GPT for
certain searches and I realized as I was
doing it you know this is the type of
thing I used to go to Google for but
chat GPT will write me a summary and I
then realized is this a threat to Google
now there are people who say chat gbt is
not a threat to Google search I think it
remains to be seen
uh I will note uh I will know I mean
obviously you're smart you're smarter
than me but uh well I don't know that
yeah
I will ask you to be careful of the
information produced via chart GPD it
often just lies yeah with confidence
right yeah and makes up research names
and articles and then when you point it
out it says sorry that makes up more
information so yeah
um I'm curious have you ever tried
Indian food uh what do you thoughts on
Indian food have I ever tried Indian
food of course I've been eating Indian
food for decades
uh um anything in particular you like
significantly I'm a big Tandoori guy I I
like the uh the Tandoori dishes
um you know honestly part of the tough
thing about talking to you about this is
I don't know how many of these are just
American dishes that don't actually
exist in India but there's a chicken
eggplant dish that I love like is that a
thing chicken aubergine
but yes yes yes uh that's uh there's
probably from Calcutta okay
um yeah uh we call it Baja that's
probably what we will pronouncer yeah
yeah yeah yeah
all right um
uh yeah anyway nice talking to you you
know one of my favorite Indian
experiences was actually in uh in London
there's an Indian breakfast spot called
dishoom and they have great
non-egg breakfast sort of like wraps and
it's absolutely fantastic River
oh that that generally sounds lovely
I've heard a lot about uh British Indian
fluid from a lot of people yeah um yeah
sounds lovely hey last question
street food there are these stereotypes
that if you have street food in a place
like Mumbai where you are that it is
extremely likely that you're going to
end up sick is that the case is that the
case for locals is it only for tourists
who aren't used to something or is that
not really true
so it is true and you're probably going
to end up like you're probably even
going to end up sick in or like within
uh the toilet for like low end
restaurants
um apparent restaurants or middle middle
restaurants it depends on the restaurant
it depends on the kind of street food
and where you're getting the street food
from
um so obviously there's no General
General stance but uh I have heard okay
so there is this thing which
as much as I hate to say there's an
admit to this not every Indian person
can actually tolerate spicy food but a
lot of people just eat the food anywhere
because it tastes so good and go to the
toilet because to them it's worth it I'm
not talking about spicy though I'm
talking from
well anyway okay I that that's fair I I
think I understand where you're going
but wow it sounds like quite a situation
let's put it that way
yeah I I've never had an experience for
um ending up sick from eating street
food okay from like any sort of health
related issues so I've never I've if
you're if you're attaining to health
related issues yeah like not coming from
Spice uh I've never had that experience
and do do you as a local do you drink
tap water is it treated or do you drink
bottled water
um I do not drink water tap water is
treated and Delhi and Mumbai are the
only places where topwater is supposed
to be safe enough to drink yeah
um but uh I would not recommend drinking
really uh I have yeah yeah I would not
recommend drinking tap water I have an
aquaguard uh okay I have a water
filtration system at home yeah and uh I
think most Indian households have water
filter filtration systems at home is
that similar wait um I'm sorry okay God
oh you're from Argentina right is that
similar in Argentina or you know in
Argentina here's the thing about
Argentina Argentina has parts of the
country that are completely like
developing parts of the world with no
running water period okay but when I go
to Buenos Aires everybody drinks the tap
water it's completely fine
oh yeah it varies greatly within the
country
okay okay okay that's quite fascinating
actually yeah now there's a guy named
Andrew taint who says it's very low brow
to drink tap water
I I yeah he also buys Lamborghinis and
gets gets arrested for human trafficking
so I don't really trust that guy much
better you know what I think you're
probably right you're probably smart not
to yeah I I think that's a smart move
River it's been an absolute pleasure
absolutely same
um thank you so much for having me all
right there is a river from Mumbai India
I want to go out on top like George
Costanza so we are going to wrap it at
that point in time uh I so appreciate
everyone I was able to speak to Let's
power through let's fix the algorithm
let's see how things are going here on
on some of these videos uh a lot is
happening and we've got likes and we've
got a lot of different things going on
okay thanks to everybody who's helping
us fix the algorithm we're back we're
doing it we're doing everything and I
will see everybody again so so soon